et heureusement qu'ils sont là c'est
superbe franchement on fait ça juste
pour qu'il y ait pas d'embrouille
C'est ça la vraie image
salut c'est Aurélie vous avez sûrement
vu cette vidéo de jeunes qui est dans
une station-service Aulnay passer sur
les réseaux en 48 heures et plus de 11
millions de vues
en fait sur portage de notre collègue
Leila il a été possible parce qu'on a
reçu un message on a pas mal de
connexion là-bas depuis un dock sur la
canne la coupe d'Aulnay des nations
qu'on a tourné et qu'on adore on vous en
parle un peu plus tard dans cette vidéo
en fait des initiatives positives il y
en a plein Aulnay et c'est pour ça qu'on
a voulu réunir les gars qui ont
participé à la CAN et ceux qui ont aidé
la station-service pour en discuter
[Musique]
vous est venue
quand les gens ils dormaient pas à cause
des klaxons un truc comme ça par contre
vas-y passer par là il y avait des
queues il y avait des que jusqu'au
rond-point sans mettre deux que les
Arabes elles veulent sortir de la cité
ça bloque le médecin il pouvait pas un
truc de fou voilà là c'est bouché de ouf
il y avait des meufs craquer
en fait c'est c'est tout seul
qui disait à quelqu'un fait si il fait
ça fait ça en fait au bout d'un moment
ça s'organiser tout seul quand cette
vidéo est sortie on a vu quelques
commentaires qui disait non en fait les
gars dans votre vidéo ils ont demandé de
l'argent automobilistes on a vérifié on
a recoupé et c'est complètement faux je
vois pas ouais j'entends pas des
polémiques
dedans ouais les gars on gère le feu à
la pompe à essence
des trucs on aurait pu remplir des cuves
tu vois grave de l'argent ça nous
intéresse même pas alors avant là le
truc de la pompe à essence les gens ils
voyaient pas au le nez comme ça tu as vu
maintenant ils ont une nouvelle image
ah vous avez fait du bien il y a eu des
détracteurs c'est un truc de guerre
en vrai si on vous parle de tout ça
c'est parce que l'année dernière on a
passé plusieurs mois Aulnay pour un
documentaire sur la coupe de l'année des
nations
tu prends tes petits ponts tu fais tes
petits ponts tu fais tes arrêts c'est
pas du Saint-Étienne c'est pas du gazon
tu tombes sur le béton tu attaques vers
le bas le terrain en pente tu attaque
vers le haut le terrain il est remonter
on a un poteau au milieu du terrain des
craquelures et des grillages les faux
sont rarement sifflées ça je vois la
dure pour un moment d'adapter pour les
équipes adverses et le temps que eux ils
s'adaptent bah nous on a déjà mis 4 5 6
buts c'est de la triche un peu c'est de
la triche c'est une autre stade c'est
c'est le béton
[Musique]
si vous remarquez bien béton il est
placé vraiment au cœur du quartier et
c'est le terrain qui rassemble
en fait ce qu'on a voulu raconter dans
ce dock au-delà du foot c'est la
solidarité entre les habitants d'Aulnay
en fait les 3000 il faut savoir c'est un
quartier on est nombreux mais on se
connaît tous là je regarde tous les gens
qui passent je les connais tous je sais
que elle c'est la merde de lui lui c'est
son frère lui lui c'est mon pote tu vois
il y en a un qui va avoir un problème
tout le monde va essayer de l'aider en
fait on peut pas laisser quelqu'un dans
son coin dans ses problèmes c'est quand
mon gars champion
le reportage c'était pas pour laquelle
c'était pour Driss j'ai même pas
j'ai pas perché et je suis là je sais
pas Washington non voilà c'était lourd
une bonne expérience il faut qu'on se
parle ça Jacques Prévert ça la mise sur
l'écran du cinéma et tout c'est
incroyable
et tout je montre ma dorment même pas
trop l'habitude pendant cette coupe de
nations on a filmé plusieurs matchs
assez dingue mais le plus fou c'était
clairement celui entre l'Algérie et le
Congo on est l'une voir la meilleure
équipe de la CAN tu me regarderas dans
les yeux tu me dis on perds 3 € à la
première mi-temps les gars
réveillez-vous il vous arrive quoi quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
2 ok le public il craque
moi j'en supporter du PSG j'en ai vécu
des déceptions football ici même je
gagne 4-0 à la 89e je vais pas être
serein
[Applaudissements]
accessoires de match qui nous file la
chair de poule j'arrête
et là c'est le drame ce dock vous pouvez
le voir en entier et gratuitement sur la
nouvelle app de brut et vous pouvez
aussi retrouver plein d'autres formats
comme des live des podcasts et les
formats bruts que vous avez l'habitude
de voir l'application
et n'hésitez pas à nous faire vos
retours en commentaire à la prochaine
[Musique]